Republicans taking a jackhammer to Merit
Garland on Capitol Hill Biden's AG
testifying under oath before the house
Judiciary Committee and getting peppered
by numerous questions over his handling
of the hunter Biden investigation I
reaffirmed today I am not the
president's lawyer
I will add I am not congress's
prosecutor have you had personal contact
with anyone at FBI headquarters about
the hunter Biden investigation I don't
really I don't I don't recollect the
answer to that question can you tell us
about any briefings or discussions that
you personally have had with Mr Weiss
regarding any and all federal
investigations of Hunter Biden under
oath my testimony today is that I
promise that the Senate I would not
intrude in his investigation what I'm
wondering is why you guys let the
statute of limitations lapse for those
tax years that dealt with barisma income
you will at the appropriate time have
the opportunity to ask Mr Weiss that
question and he will no doubt address it
in the public report that will be
transmitted to the Congress then Garland
blowing his lid at a GOP lawmaker who
criticized the justice department for
targeting Catholic and pro-life groups
do you agree that traditional Catholics
are violent extremists yes or no yes
idea that someone with my family
background
would discriminate against any religion
is so outrageous the soul absurds their
attorney general it was your FBI that
did this it was your FBI that was
sending and we have the memos we have
the emails we're sending undercover
agents into Catholic churches
and Hunter is still trying to get
sweetheart deals he tried to cite
traffic in a bid to plead not guilty by
video arraignment to felony gun charges
but the judge says he better show up so
Harold because you have absolutely
nothing to do in the daytime you you
watch the entire thing must be nice
uh how do you think both sides did
well I didn't I didn't view it as both
sides I thought that I didn't fully
understand the purpose of the hearing
but Congress has every right to exercise
oversight uh on any matter that that
they want I thought that he answered I
didn't see the whole hearing I saw
pieces of a head on the background in my
office and I I watched that exchange
because it looked like they were getting
heated that Congressman was asking about
the Catholic church if you if we played
his answer he was he seemed offended it
he was being asked this question because
um cigarland is Jewish his family
members a grandfather I believe that
there's relatives that were Holocaust
Survivors and his mom worked in the
elderly services Community uh serving
them in Chicago so I think he was he was
offended by that and maybe he should
have answered right off but I think he
was just so taken aback to I think that
um it's interesting to me the oversight
that these guys want to want to exercise
because they I saw Jim Jordan go down to
the border and they conducted a hearing
there I want them to give us a tough
bill to make the White House
uncomfortable meaning things that they
don't want to do whether it's fighting
fentanyl fighting the illegal entry or
fentanyl and certainly those are coming
across the border illegally give us a
cry just so many things they could be
doing but I didn't understand the
purpose of the hearing I thought it went
on it went on way a long long time he
answered their questions I think what
they wanted to do was try to get up
there the hunter Biden thing which is
fine but he he's he's answered the
questions and I I and I would remind
everybody Chris Ray is a trump appointee
the FBI director Bill Barr was a trump
appointee I remind everybody that Mr
Weiss was a trump appointee now again
this is not to to get into anyone's skin
here but we talk about this stuff like
it's so political it is they were
appointed by Republicans and the
Democrats held him over this this
Democratic president held him over judge
I can see you squirming over there
you're ready to explode first of all I'm
your friend now
your friend and I love you but you're
wrong first of all you said he answered
all the questions he didn't answer the
questions he was well does he doesn't
recollect if he's had contact with the
FBI about Hunter Biden's case is there
anything more absurd in the universe
than that statement and I'll tell you
why doesn't recollect is a classic
example of a potential defendant who's
trying to avoid a perjury trap all right
because we all know and everyone in
America knows that Merrick Garland had
to do something about that case and I'll
tell you why because it went on for five
years you don't think at some point
Merrick Garland who appointed David
Weiss and said oh wait a minute wait a
minute I don't want to spend a lot of
time on this Harold but the Democrats
get a choice for a United States
Attorney he was a Democrat choice and
that's a deal that was made all right so
David Wise is a democratic Choice
against the blue slip and he's now the
U.S attorney now five years you you
don't think Joe Biden is saying to
Merrick Garland what's going on with my
son's case what's going on with the
statute of limitation what's going on I
hear that there are whistleblowers out
there you know why is this thing taking
years and he knows his boss is saying my
son's son nothing wrong and the concept
the idea that I don't ever remember
talking to the FBI is a is it it is the
excuse that everyone used to not get
caught in the perjury chap trap now the
other thing is he said he made the
decision to call to make David Weiss or
he didn't make the decision to make
David Wise special counsel okay so even
after all of the all of the blow up of
that plea deal that had never been done
before in the history of the Department
of Justice making that plea offer he he
says I never considered anyone but wise
because I didn't want to disrupt things
so why do you appoint the same guy who
put a deal in that blew up and is the
whole reason behind the hearing which is
Americans feeling that we have a dual
system of justice all right um I want to
go to Jesse I have the debate rules if
your name gets invoked
we would go on forever Jesse before you
answer this question just remember that
Howard Stern might be watching so
consider your answer uh what do you
think how do you think Merrick Garland
did how do you think the Republicans did
so
gar conducts investigations of
everything and everybody
can't answer anything because
everything's under investigation perfect
yeah so if things weren't being
investigated then he could answer
so he just investigates everybody so he
doesn't have to answer a stupid question
I don't like this it's boring and even
Eric Holder was more forthcoming Bill
Barr has been more forthcoming his
answer was I made a promise to the
Senate so I can't answer oh you made a
little promise oh did you made a little
promise oh don't answer I can't answer
this question talk to Weiss the special
counsel about it he's not testifying
you're testifying answer the question or
I don't recollect the answer to that
question you don't recollect we don't
recollect what they're asking or you
don't recollect the answer it's too
early for me I don't like it I hate to
fact check you Harold don't like to but
will Weiss was blue slipped he wasn't
Trump appointed Carper and the other guy
with the bald head Delaware said here's
our guy he's been a Democrat his whole
career
Hunter is now saying he wants to appear
via Zoom because he doesn't want to like
gnarl up traffic in Delaware okay heaven
forbid Donald Trump swirled up traffic
in like New York and Atlanta and Miami
and Washington DC I mean he's he's the
president former president secret
service everywhere helicopters they had
like look Hunter is going to snarl up
traffic in Wilmington real you're not
that important Hunter yeah they don't
even have cars in Wilmington Dana worse
than buggy yes exactly what did you make
of this hearing well I don't have a lot
more to add here I do think it was
interesting though that one of the
things he kept saying was he couldn't
speak to all of these supposed scandals
at his department and he insisted that
he only knew what was in the media yes
so I mean but I also know what's in the
media but I'm not in charge of the
justice department and if I had heard of
these things I would have said I need a
brief on that what's going on here tell
me a little bit more about this and it's
curious that he is so incurious about
his own agency the other thing is I'm
not sure there's a better representative
of the Biden Administration putting this
moderate face on somebody who's actually
doing a lot of what the wants right so
remember when President Obama appointed
him or wanted to appoint him to the
Supreme Court or nominated him and
McConnell said I think we're going to
hold on that because you know Scalia
just died we're just going to wait on
that but Obama kept saying what are you
talking about he's the most moderate
most Centrist he's even kind of a
center-right kind of guy that
Republicans should love him yeah well
I guess we learned another lesson look
at that now Dana look at that no
seriously look at it look at it all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else